Kaum ein anderer Bereich wächst derzeit so
krass wie der Online-Handel und damit auch
die Paketzustellung.
Paketboten kommen mit ihrer Arbeit überhaupt
nicht mehr hinterher und genau hier setzt
die Idee des Skype-Gründers Ahti Heinla an.
Er hat Paketroboter entwickelt, die tatsächlich
das Potential haben, die Logistikbranche komplett
zu revolutionieren Willkommen bei Clixom Science
& Fiction Hier gibt es täglich faszinierende
Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal, nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts.
Die Idee stammt von dem Multimillionär Ahti
Heinla.
Er hat vor einigen Jahren den Internet-Telefondienst
Skype gegründet und dann für acht Milliarden
Dollar an Microsoft verkauft.
Damit hat er tatsächlich die Kommunikationsbranche
revolutioniert, denn zuvor war weltweites
Telefonieren teuer - geschweige denn, dabei
noch Bilder zu übertragen.
Jetzt arbeitet Heinla an Nichts geringerem
als an der Revolution der Logistikbranche.
Mit seinem Unternehmen “Starship Technologies”
hatte er zunächst an einem Fahrzeug für
den Mars getüftelt.
Bei dem NASA-Wettbewerb ging Heinla allerdings
nicht als Sieger hervor - seitdem konzentriert
er sich mit seinen Roboterwagen auf den Straßenverkehr
- mitten in der Stadt.
Und genau die sollen schon in naher Zukunft
die Paketzustellung, wie wir sie kennen, komplett
auf den Kopf stellen.
Denn statt Paketboten, die mit ihren Wagen
die Stadt verstopfen und von Tür zu Tür
hetzen, sollen uns nach Heinlas Plan künftig
Liefer-Roboter die Pakete direkt an die Tür
bringen.
Denn genau dieser letzte Schritt, das Abliefern
beim Kunden Zuhause, ist die größte Herausforderung.
Und sie wird immer größer, denn na klar
- Online wird mittlerweile ALLES bestellt.
Egal ob Kleidung, Möbel oder Essen.
Und der Job des Paketzustellers ist wirklich
mehr als hart: Es gibt viel zu Schleppen,
ohne Überstunden ist die ganze Arbeit eigentlich
kaum zu Stemmen und zudem sind sie meist auch
noch wirklich schlecht bezahlt.
Zu viel Stau, zu wenige Parkplätze und viele
Kunden, die nicht Zuhause sind, um ihr bestelltes
Paket überhaupt anzunehmen, kommen dazu.
Schon heute kann Statistiken zufolge jedes
dritte Paket nicht beim ersten Versuch an
den Kunden zugestellt werden.
Viele Gründe, die dafür sorgen, dass Heinlas
Plan schon jetzt aufgeht.
Im Testbetrieb in verschiedenen Städten weltweit
holen die Roboter die Pakete in einem Depot
ihres Stadtteils ab und verteilen sie in einem
Radius von sechs Kilometern an die Kunden.
2017 wurde das Konzept auch in Deutschland
getestet: Unter anderem von dem Paketdienst
Hermes in Hamburg und ebenso von einigen Lieferservices.
In der Testphase sind oft noch Mitarbeiter
dabei, die die Roboter begleiten und vor allem
Fragen von den Passanten drum herum beantworten!
Die Kooperationspartner wie Pizzadienste etwa
bezahlen dann pro Ablieferung.
Etwa 200 Testfahrzeuge waren in Hamburg am
Start.
Nach Angaben des Herstellers gab es bisher
weder Unfälle, Diebstähle oder Hackerangriffe.
Dennoch ist die Gesetzeslage in Deutschland
noch recht schwierig für Heinlas Idee.
Denn das deutsche Verkehrsrecht erteilt keine
allgemein gültigen Erlaubnisse, wie und wo
die Roboter fahren dürfen.
Jede Kommune müsste einzeln entscheiden,
ob sie auf den Fußwegen unterwegs sein dürften.
Anders dagegen in Österreich, wo das erlaubt
ist oder auch in einigen US-Bundesstaaten
wie Washington, wo die Fahrzeuge völlig uneingeschränkt
unterwegs sein dürfen.
Dennoch malt sich Heinla die Zukunft ziemlich
rosig aus.
Er stammt aus Estland und dort garantiert
das Grundgesetz jedem Bürger das Recht auf
schnelles Internet.
Der Skype-Gründer geht davon aus, dass in
naher Zukunft sehr viele Menschen von Zuhause
aus arbeiten werden - der Transport von Passagieren
wird seinem Plan zufolge abnehmen, ganz anders
dagegen der Transport von Waren.
Und bisher läuft es ganz gut für Heinlas
Liefer-Roboter.
Auch der automatische Batterietausch ist schon
ausgetüftelt.
An Tausch-Stationen, die entlang der Lieferstrecken
aufgebaut sind, wechselt ein Greifarm die
alte Batterie gegen eine neue.
Das Ganze dauert drei Minuten.
Unter den Deckel passen übrigens Pakete mit
einem Gewicht von bis zu zehn Kilogramm.
Und so funktioniert das Ganze konkret: Der
Empfänger bekommt eine Nachricht auf sein
Handy - statt dem Klingeln an der Haustür
- und kann dann die Kiste öffnen.
Und zwar mit einem Code, den er vorher auf
sein Smartphone bekommen hat.
Das Coole daran: Der Roboter liefert nicht
nur an die Haustür, sondern auch an die Bahnhaltestelle,
den Biergarten oder eine Parkbank.
Außerdem mega praktisch: Er braucht keinen
Parkplatz und ist auch abends unterwegs.
Die Geräte zeichnen bei ihren Fahrten mit
neun Kameras die Umgebung auf; viele Sensoren
verhindern, dass er in andere Straßenverkehrsteilnehmer
kracht.
Roboterexperten und -expertinnen in Heinlas
Büro können können bis zu 100 Fahrzeuge
gleichzeitig im Auge behalten, jederzeit eingreifen
und die Fahrzeuge manuell steuern.
Schon 2020 Jahren soll nach Heinlas Vision
die Roboter Zustellung auf dasselbe Preisniveau
kommen wie die herkömmliche Paketzustellung
mit menschlichen Boten.
Danach sollen sie dann in Massenfertigung
hergestellt werden, sodass dann nichts mehr
im Weg steht für seinen langfristigen Plan:
Denn dann soll es in Städten mehr Lieferroboter
als Autos geben!
Autonomes fahren bei Paketrobotern scheint
ja ganz gut zu funktionieren und es ist bei
den kleinen Kisten ja ziemlich ungefährlich
anders bei autos.
Sollten selbstfahrende Autos dich umbringen
dürfen?
What?
Das Video von Doktor Whatson.
Anklicken, anschauen und Doktor Whatson abonnieren!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!